this is the more sane reading for
reviewer Richard Wakeling FIFA 23 marks
the end of an era for the long-running
series after an almost 30-year
partnership that began with players like
David Platt gracing the cover EA Sports
has parted ways with the football's
governing body over a licensing
disagreement future games in the series
will now drop the FIFA name in favor of
a new EA Sports FC moniker not that
you'd be able to tell from playing FIFA
23 mind you despite being the last game
adorned with the household name it's
business as usual both on and off the
pitch for EA's latest footballing Sim
there are a few new additions spread
across its various game modes and
Ultimate Team sees its most significant
change in years but for the most part
FIFA swan song is a game of minor
iterations
thank you
it begins once you step out onto its
exquisitely rendered grass with the
introduction of high promotion 2
ensuring that each and every match in
FIFA 23 looks and feels more authentic
and immersive the Innovative technology
first appeared in last year's game and
allowed the developers to motion capture
all 22 players in a real life match by
capturing every minute detail and
context-specific action across a full 90
minutes and implementing it into FIFA's
gameplay there was a plethora of new
animations that edge the simulation
closer to reality with hypermotion 2
FIFA 23 simply expands on its
predecessor by obtaining even more data
from the full length matches and
training sessions with professional
teams this means that players move
across the pitch collide with each other
and strike the ball with increased
fluidity and an added sense of realism
the impact this has on the gameplay is
palpable most notably in regards to the
game's overall Pace I said the same
thing last year but FIFA 23 is
considerably slower than its precursor
fleet-footed players can still be
devastating but they work best in short
bursts using their acceleration to gain
a yard of space or dashing past the
static back line for the most part goals
are created through sweeping passing
moves picking out a teammate is more
consistent this time around and is a
responsiveness and satisfying zip to
passes that constitutes genuine
excitement when you're able to spray the
ball around to create openings and
eventually finish a move off with the
ball nestled in the bottom corner to
counteract this Defenders feel more
intelligent in regards to their
positioning and successful tackles
frequently end with you actually
regaining possession joking is also an
effective Avenue for winning the ball
back especially when using a stronger
player whose abilities utilize their
strength to great effect and slide
tackling finally feels viable again
despite these changes FIFA 23 doesn't
feel like a significantly poured over
over last year's game it feels very much
a case of incremental improvements on
what was previously established so it's
still a good game just not one that
feels particularly new in fact one of
the only new additions is the Advent of
power shots which sees your player take
an exaggerated wind-up before launching
the ball towards the goal in thunderous
fashion the dramatic zooming that
accompanies each windup makes the
PowerShot feel like it belongs in Mario
Strikers or Captain Tsubasa rather than
the latest FIFA but there's no more
satisfying way to score a goal in FIFA
23. most of the time however it takes so
long to fire off one of these shots that
you'll be dispossessed before the ball
can even leave your foot and when it
does accuracy varies from pinpoint
screamers that fly into the top corner
to Wild lashes that end up closer to the
corner flag this creates an inviting
element of risk and reward where they
might be better and safer options but
nothing beats Paul driving a shot that
the net can barely contain other new
additions are similarly positive the
women's game features more prominently
than ever before with the inclusion of
Club football joining the assortment of
international teams that have been in
the game since FIFA 16. there are only
two leagues to choose from the English
women's super league and the French
division won our camera but finally
being able to play as clubs like Chelsea
and Lyon is a long overdue addition
hyper motion 2 was also used to capture
women's football so players like cover
star Sam Kerr and Arsenal Striker Vivian
miyadima move as you would expect and
feel distinct from their male
counterparts the only downside is that
you can only use women's teams in
friendlies and tournaments so you can
play through a full season in either
division but you're restricted to a
single campaign and aren't able to
purchase players or engage in any of the
other amenities found in FIFA's career
mode speaking of which career mode is
much the same as before one of the new
features lets you take part in playable
highlights of games rather than having
to play through the full 90 minutes
ensuring that you still have an impact
in matches you're simulating if you opt
for a player career you can now
ostensibly shape their personality to
receive Buffs for certain attributes
assisting a teammate will generate
heartbeat points for instance whereas
holding onto the ball and scoring
yourself will generate both Maverick and
virtuoso points these points will then
boost attributes related to each
personality style whether it provides a
bump to dribbling and finishing or
crossing and ball control you can also
spend in-game money to gain additional
points by say donating to a charity or
purchasing an expensive watch it's a
binary system that uses the word
personality very easily but it's a step
in the right direction even if it mostly
Fades into the background and doesn't
drastically change the feel of career
mode in a PR Savvy move AFC Richmond is
also a playable team in FIFA 23 you'll
see Ted lasso patrolling the touchline
and emerge from the tunnel with a lineup
featuring the likes of Roy Ken and Jamie
tar it's a fun gimmick for fans of the
show although it doesn't really go
anywhere beyond the visuals you can
select Richmond in career mode and stick
them in the Premier League but press
conferences still use the same generic
answers so don't expect any Ted specific
perfect lines selecting Richmond also
puts you in a bit of a hole to begin
with because the squad is so small the
bench and fullback positions are filled
by generic players in lieu of then not
being enough characters in the show but
it feels like an oversight that there
aren't more of them you need to spend
your first transfer window buying
backups for nearly every position so
being able to use Richmond in career
mode doesn't seem particularly well
thought out of course EA's primary focus
in FIFA 23 is Ultimate Team the annual
Money Maker has reworked its chemistry
system this time around with the maximum
possible chemistry your team can reach
now 33 instead of 100 you're still
rewarded for having teammates that share
leagues clubs and or nationalities but
these players don't need to be adjacent
to one another in order to receive the
attribute boosts crucially there's also
no punishment for fielding a player with
zero chemistry you can stick messy on
the wing of a team that's otherwise
comprised of Serie A R players and his
attributes won't suddenly decrease
because there are no Argentine or PSG
players now him this Transformer's
Ultimate Team into the fantasy football
game mode it was initially billed as
cards that very few people would have
used previously will now be viable
because you don't have to worry about
their links to other players in your
team your squad has the potential to be
more diverse and unique to you while the
decision to amend position modifier
cards is also a positive one in FIFA 23
these cards can only be used to move a
player to their real life secondary
position putting an end to teams
deploying five Strikers across the
Midfield with no negative consequences
the only downside of this chemistry
revamp is the effect it has on Squad
building challenges previously you could
stick players in any position and
Achieve just enough chemistry via their
shared nationality and other factors to
be able to submit the squad that's more
difficult now because players use the
outside of their natural position
account for zero chemistry and the
requirements for some of these sbcs ask
you to submit a squad where the
chemistry rating of each player is at
least one or two this feels like another
move designed to entice players into
buying packs in order to acquire more
cards that might potentially be usable
in different sbcs it's a sure sign if
you ever needed one that the predatory
aspects of Ultimate Team aren't going
away anytime soon
the issue of packed transparency is
still obfuscated and those who spend the
most real money will end up with the
best teams the addition of moments does
at least give you another Avenue to
acquire packs without spending a dime
these are bite-sized challenges that
vary in difficulty tasking you with
scoring a hat trick with mbappe or
curling a free kick in from 30 yards out
their quick fire nature makes it easy to
accrue rewards after an hour or so and
it also proves to be a decent learning
tool for newcomers the only downside is
that you're taken back to the moments
menu between each challenge rather than
immediately jumping to the next one like
you're able to do on Madden this minor
annoyance isn't enough to detract from
what is an enjoyable new addition though
FIFA 23 is a fitting end to an error
successfully capturing the essence of
the beautiful game alongside the
disheartening practices of the profit
hungry vultures circling overhead it's
as much about greed as it is about
scoring a screamer a game where the
on-pitch action has been refined with
Slicker passing more effective defending
and Myriad animations that bring it all
to life yet the shadow of gambling looms
over it all this has been the case since
ultimate team was introduced 14 years
ago so none of this comes as a surprise
and with the next World Cup taking place
in Qatar a country known for sports
watching its human rights record it's
all par for the course when it comes to
football the age of FIFA might be coming
to an end but EA Sports FC is likely to
kick off in much the same way offering a
fantastic game of football that's
otherwise consumed by an exploitative
cash grab
[Music]